we got this story from the Daily Mail
new graphic reveals extent of the great
resignation how many have quit their job
since 2021 and which Industries have
been hit the hardest I saw this and it's
kind of crazy the great resignation
isn't over yet November 2022
4.17 million the number of people
quitting their jobs in the U.S
seasonally adjusted
so uh
I don't know people are quitting their
jobs nobody wants to work people are
unhealthy they're doing drugs
is this a it's an opportunity black pill
or opportunity for a new industry there
are workers that want to get jobs
I feel like a lot of this is my
generation too like gen Z is we've been
fed this idea I call them the
participation trophy Generations because
they expect everything handed to them
they expect to be paid 15 to 30 dollars
for flipping burgers at a McDonald's
meanwhile you know someone with a
doctorate is being paid 30 an hour I
mean this is the generation and you're
seeing it with the Millennials and with
Gen Z and a few other Generations is
they don't want to work and they don't
find Value in actually working hard
um well I don't know for sure I I
appreciate that you said that but I
don't know them so I'd have to go Case
by case but I I for sure I believe
they're they're quitting jobs they hate
doesn't mean that they're gonna hate the
next job they get but there's also a lot
of inflation as Ian is saying and
there's also a record amount of of the
dollar being absolutely devalued to the
point where people are like why should I
work when I could barely make ends meet
when I could just get a government check
right so that's also going into the
perspective here and at the same time
when you're giving everyone
participation trophies when you're when
you're hiring and promoting based off
race and based off uh you know sexuality
rather than actual Merit what gives you
the incentive to actually be good at
your job when you know you're only going
to be selected because of the way you
look or what you decide to shove up
inside of you right so I think that or
not shove up inside of you the value of
time is or to shove something inside
someone else have you guys clarify that
like working for hourly is maybe a
defunct method of of payment for uh
employees these days because like I feel
like you can get so much more done per
hour than you used to be able to do
you're thinking about the wrong jobs
though I think for somebody who's got a
specific job like I need you here right
handing bags of food out for three hours
hourly makes sense
yeah you're not going to do it by like
for every bag you hand out you get 10
cents you know what I mean because man
our wave wage slave sucks do you guys
ever do that I mean I pretty much
everybody else let's try that let's do
that let's uh when I open the coffee
shop I'll say for every cup of coffee
you hand out I'll give you a dime
dude you know they'll be upselling that
you want another one you want two cups
you sure your buddy your buddy's here
but hasn't had one yet I think the
problem isn't making no money oh not on
top of there do it on top of the salary
no I'm saying like if if we want to if
we want to talk about hourly versus
actual sales it's like what what are you
paying a person for it's like the funny
thing about the the left is a funny meme
I saw it said
the left the marxists are like the
profits should all be shared among the
workers and the guy responds and says
then if the company and cruise debt and
loses money then the debt needs to be
split among all workers as well and then
the Marxist gets all angry because they
never talk about that one but let's put
it this way the Marxist view would be
like okay how about this instead of
paying you an hourly wage for you to
sell coffee I'll give you a portion of
the labor you produce like okay so uh I
work to get the cups in the coffee you
work to distribute them I will share
with you a portion of the revenue I
think they'd end up making like
substantially less money doing that like
imagine you're working at a coffee shop
and it's a slow morning
it's like well I made 30 cents today
because no one came in for coffee yeah
well too bad that's you know that's it's
equality right I've been there as a
waiter waiting two dollars and Thirteen
Cents an hour plus tips and some days
you get three tables walk out with like
14 bucks yep yeah that's that's the most
criminal thing to be in the US is like
that you pay waiters like a dollar an
hour and then you say oh well they'll
make it in tips I never understood the
food industry is hell if any of you guys
have ever worked in it it actually like
being a server is a terrible job it
depends because you can get that good
one where you 250 meals at night and you
get like seven tables that's that's so
rare though usually your serving soy
slop on plates to people running around
I mean you have hundreds of people
filling and you have sections cut out
for certain Services you're serving 10
people at a time being a server you're
probably gonna be a server at a place
like Applebee's or like LongHorn
Steakhouse or something along those
lines those are the most probably most
most uh uh profitable yeah profitable
but the most common restaurants that you
that you that you find and you're not
finding wealthy people going in there
dropping a lot of money people that go
to you know people that go to LongHorn
Steakhouse are not like I'm gonna go out
and spend 300 and then tip the you know
waiter or a 100 bucks they're they're
gonna go They're Gonna spend their 150
or whatever for their family and they're
gonna give the waiter 15 because yeah
I've been there East Side Marios Bo's
Tavern list goes on man I went to so
many different restaurants they're not
those places the predominant
uh you know the predominant restaurants
in the US aren't places where people go
that you know have a lot of money that
they're going for a little treat for
their family you know well especially
now I mean tipping is going down too in
the food industry is because the prices
are going yeah you're the same thing you
would get a few years ago at your
favorite restaurant for ten dollars
you're now spending twenty dollars on so
then you're minimizing your tip as well
I I guess you're supposed to well you're
supposed to not do whatever you want you
don't have to tip if you don't want to
but give them 20 of the bill so if the
the food cost doubles then they'll be
getting double the tip
um but that's discouraging a lot of
people from even eating out now too is
because they don't want they don't have
that money necessarily to tip where's
all the money what happened it went to
the Ukraine are there like just really
rich people that are hoarding their
hundreds of billions offshore where's
all the money well what do you mean
they're just printed like seven four
trillion or six trillion or something
you know big Pharma is creating more
billionaires than any other industry out
there right now and during covid there
was a large transfer of wealth biggest
from wealth transfer in the history
right I think the history of the world
yeah uh where we saw the most of money
money go from everyone to the
billionaire class and the billionaires
double tripled their wealth while
everyone else was left holding the bag
as of course they weren't allowed to
have private Enterprise they weren't
allowed to have businesses as the
government came in and said Mom and Pop
you got to shut down Walmart has to be
open strip clubs liquor store you guys
can stay open it's leading me to want to
be like workers of the World Unite let's
take our money back but we all know how
that turned out so we're trying to
figure out a different way like we're
trying to find out a 21st century hammer
and sickly yeah I've got plenty oh you
have right here these guys hammers no
thank you well we know are you sure you
want this job
I will reign in uh
I think it's funny I mean like you know
you guys are more uh libertarian
anarchists Ian's more uh government yes
liberal elections I'm not being honest
because I think a lot of people are
feeling what I'm feeling the frustration
is building I'm like you know what
popular stuff Rising if that's what it
takes we'll just get a bunch of famous
people to scream it out on date on
Thursday at two and then that's when it
begins I mean you are has never worked
populist no they don't you're right
they've always ended up with worse
governments the only like people say
that America I'm gonna get into a little
rain here people say that the United
States is not a unique country there's
nothing special about the United States
the United States is one of a
vanishingly few countries in the in the
world that had a revolution and came out
better on the other side right like the
revolution that the United States had
when we separated from the British the
United States was a more free country
and then went on to become an even more
free country as we continued to work
towards the ideal set forth in the in
the Bill of Rights in the Constitution
you know what and if people are asking
the question that's Tim playing with the
gooch sound stick healing energy bar you
know what's appalling to me is is when
we literally overthrew this government
and we I mean we started I can't say
wait but our ancestors and I mean the
founding fathers started you know
America what is America now is we were
actually being prized I mean taxed
decently fairly okay and now you see
what's going on these 87 000 IRS agents
and everything else and it's like where
you know I keep I keep hearing from all
these people that Revolution is in our
blood and it's like where well that's
why I brought this up look at the
Declaration of Independence I mean the
list of grievances was more than just
happened yeah of course you know so I
bring it up because I'm feeling grieved
right now at the system like the mass
redistribution of wealth to the top
these things of people consolidating
wealth how do we we revolt against that
or change that without creating a
populist violent populist uprisingly no
it doesn't work legal and local you get
involved in your local area local
governments local government you get
people that share your opinions and
political views elected to local office
because the people that have the most
effect in your life are the local
politicians you also have the most
opportunity to affect their lives if you
go down to the general store or whatever
and you bump into your selectment or
your mayor or whatever you can give him
the stink eye you know give him dirty
looks and let him know that he's unhappy
and you're going to have the best chance
of having a response from your local
government than you will from state or
federal but then after you're local then
you go for State because the state
governments have an enormous amount of
uh ability to pass laws and legislate
they have all kinds of authority to
legislate there's only a handful of
things that they're prevented from
legislating by the federal government so
to think that we need to overthrow the
federal government is a vast is a
massive error what you need to do is get
James get in touch with James Lindsey
and help get people elected to school
boards right in your local area because
that is how you affect the most
immediate change and it's also peaceful
and it's legal well I I agree with I
mean local is always more important than
Federal I mean my reporting on the drag
stuff I mean the past half a year that
I've been doing it in Texas alone I mean
the GOP is already in Texas Texas GOP
has already made it one of their top
priorities is to basically reword the
coding of the sexual uh basically um
involvement with Children what you can
do in front of children and now the
legislation the new legislative session
is coming around I mean they're talking
about passing laws to ban children from
these sexually explicit shows I mean so
anyone can make a difference reference
on a local level but you just need to
know how to do it I need to do it in an
effective way I'm not so sure the laws
are going to fix that problem though
they're just going to go underground
no no I don't think so either in
Arkansas they're gonna they're trying to
make drag shows adult the same things
like whatever but uh it's already
illegal to perform sex acts simulated
sex acts in front of children in Texas
and they don't do anything about it yeah
well I think it's the way that the the
penal code or I mean I'm not sure I'm
not really well written on law but the
way that it's written is that's what
allows it to happen so the GOP is going
to go in and try and tighten it up I
don't have that much faith in the GOP
obviously for very understandable
reasons I I disagree I mean I'm pretty
sure that if you walked up to a
playground and did what those people did
oh you'd be and you'd be in jail so
there's no difference yeah the issue is
that the cops culturally are unwilling
to enforce well I mean Dallas PD Fresno
I mean Frisco PD all of these places
that I've covered these drag shows in
they know what's going on is wrong but
they're not willing to actually do
anything about it yeah they're terrified
I mean and it's understandable in a lot
of aspects are the same way it's like
someone needs to be the first officer to
make an arrest to go in here and to drag
these drag queens or drag Kings because
they are all men at this point that's
what we should call them did you just
say that cops in Texas are scared crazy
you valday was terrified I am shocked
that police officers in the great state
of Texas are frightened guys
hey you guys aren't backing the blue
enough no I think that's the root
problem here
I back good ideas I gotta lift the
people I don't I don't know when if
these officers walked in and they I mean
they dragged these people out I would be
I mean clapping and cheering jumping up
and down with Joy but you just don't see
that no one is actually willing to be
the first person to do this because they
know what's going to cause a lot of crap
for them in the future which someone
needs to stand up and do it but it's
just a matter of who and when I hear
Florida is doing some actions against
those uh kind of dragons at least
they're trying to yeah so buddy mining
New Hampshire is also doing the same
thing he's in the New Hampshire State
Legislature Mike Belcher follow him on
Twitter uh he's uh he's he's got actual
legislation that he's presented to
keep the kind of woke mind virus stuff
out of
um the law in New Hampshire so but if
people look it's only a matter of time
these laws get overturned get removed if
people don't speak up because I said it
before I'll say it again if there's you
and a leftist and you're like I'm too
scared to speak the leftist is screaming
non-stop the children only hear the
leftist right so that's it you got to
speak up you you hit the nail in the
head a long time ago when you talked
about how the leftists are the ones
that'll make the noise and that's why
they don't get banned from platforms
look at how bad right though
right-wingers are actually organizing
things too that's what I've noticed the
past few years is the only thing that's
like actually been like a successful an
organization of the right has been like
you know like the stop the steal and the
mega the Mega Million marches those are
really the only things that I've seen
that have like been semi-successful I
mean anytime you go I mean even in Texas
the people you know the Catholics and
everybody that organize against these
drag shows they're severely outnumbered
every single time by local John Brown
Gun Club in antifa and you're in Texas
yeah
crazy in Texas
yeah everyone talks about how much they
love Texas and I am one not to support
that I mean one it's flat and two there
is more sexual exploitation of children
going on there than I would argue
anywhere in the country that's true in
the Border too the border is out of
control I read a story about some lady
she like she said she walked out of a
bar it was like a post on Reddit I think
and her boyfriend and his two friends
were like 10 feet in front of her a car
creeps up they open the door jump out
grab her and try dragging her in starts
screaming the her boyfriend and the guys
run over and grab her pull her out of
the car before they and then they speed
off it's just like well and you can just
Street kidnap women in Texas and then
drive them well and you can literally
walk down I mean of like two years ago
this didn't exist really I mean language
barriers in Dallas did not really exist
but now if you go and try and film like
a man on the street video or anything in
Dallas you're going to run into people
that do not even speak English I mean
this is a new thing happening you're
having hundreds of thousands and
millions of people coming over the Texas
border and then instead of actually
deporting them Greg Abbott just wants to
ship them to other states which are
still in our country that's right it's a
nice publicity stunt go the first few
times you do it but you're still in your
country people people are telling me
well they don't have the right to deport
it's a federal thing they can't Deport
it's a state thing and I'm like so send
them into the country I mean that's
crazy yeah send them farther in where
they can spread out and diversify even
more it's a great idea yeah you think so
Texas should be able to deport
absolutely yeah absolutely I mean you
know the whole Texas sovereignty it's a
load of crap I mean Texas should be able
to deport absolutely anybody that they
want if you're Crossing you know
actually last time I was at the border
and doing some border reporting I mean
there was thousands coming over it was
insane it's something I've never seen
before I crossed the Rio Grande with
these people and I actually was
capturing these people as they were
being processed on video and National
Guard and border patrol pulled their
cars in front and told me that I'm not
able to record because at it was the
request of these migrants I said okay so
the migrants who aren't even citizens
here they have more rights than me as a
member of the press freedom of the press
it doesn't exist like they're right
Trump's mind and this should have said
yes so it's like there's there's a very
big problem going on at the border
specifically in Texas and we're going to
feel it for a very long time all right
uh uh White pillar black belt do you
think we're heading we're going to make
it through this do you think it's going
to get worse I mean I like to say you
know I I like to take a black pill in
the morning and then a white pill at
night before I go to bed that's what I
like to do but everything is going to
get worse before it gets better that's
how it always goes it's always going to
get significantly worse and yeah is
there going to be an upturn I do think
there eventually will be an upturn but
the next few years they're going to get
pretty bad so you're speedballing
basically it's like the crack to the
baby but
to me it's kind of like might as well
working out you know you got to
traumatize the muscle and then let it
rest so whether or not we've got to
break it down and then rebuild it yeah
and we're in the breakdown phase right
now yeah
what does it infiltrate destroy and
rebuild yeah the easiest way to destroy
something is from within and that's
exactly what you're seeing right now
across the country yeah true that you
just gotta we got to protect the IRS you
know
you gotta like use your force of will to
manipulate people's emotions to make
them more American like to make them
more Liberty Liberty loving we're in a
battle of wills of spirits why are you
hurting me I haven't been here and I
haven't seen you in like three weeks or
something and now you're harming me
being a culture War baby and I fight
dirty are you ready that was a little
bit more your your your point is right
the but the thing is Americans and
specifically children need to be taught
that America is not an evil place right
that it that a liberal Society is not
inherently bad because what they're
being taught is that a liberal Society
is bad because a liberal society makes
room for racism that's what they're
taught when you when you hear critical
race Theory the critical part is
criticizing the the ex the existing
structures which is our society and
their use race is the means that they're
using to criticize now America is a very
beautiful thing in a beautiful place but
it's the leaders in charge that's what
people need to be taught in America it's
not it's not about the leaders in charge
it's that it's people need to understand
the fun fundamental ideals that the
United States was founded on and they
need to understand why they are
important it is important to know why
property rights matter important to know
why Free Speech matters these things
matter to our society and without them
we do not have the society that we have
grown with thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time